GAETZ, ATY ISW.T IN AMERICA HA
INCITED FARE POLITICAL
THE RIGHT.  CONGRESSMAN MAST PE
SHY, AND DON'T BE Y.
>> Reporter: THE 38-YEAR-OLD
REPUBLICAN FROM FLORIDA HAS ON T
YEARS.
BUT HIS FLAIR DRAMHAS
CAPTURED NATIONAL
ANYBODY.
>> Reporter:--
>> OURSORRY, NOT SORRY.
>> Rep AN
UPROOTING ONCE FEATURED ON THE
BIG SCREEN.
OO GOOD
>> Reporter: HE GREW UP IN T O M
TRUSHOW."
>> ONE DAY SOME OD SWSA D TELLS
MOVIE IN THIS HOUSE,ING
JIM CARREY.
>> IN HITE PICKET HOUSE INAS T M
SUFFERED COMPLICATIONS WHILE TH
REFUSED TO TERMINATEHEEGE ANSSIN
GAETZ, WAI
CONTRIBUTED TO HIS ANTI-ABORTION
STCEN HE
>> EVERY CHAE I GET TO STAND LI
WEALTHY AND POWERF IE
THROUGH  COMP EVENTLITICSS ELEC
FLORIDA STE USISIN
BECOME A POWER PLAYER INDA
POLITICS.
>> HE THE NEW AMERICA. IS THW
A STATE HOUSE.
>> THERE I CAUSEN T ORNGORN STR
r: MATRAGED HIFAMILY NE  EASIL
FIRS AO BECOME A STATE
TIVE IN 2010.
LONGSIDE HS READY TO TAXES TODAH
>> IT IS MY PRIVILEG
T OF THE
FLOR
WELL, THEM
NORTHWEST FLORIDA, DON GAETZ.
>> Reporter: TOOK ON THEME BABYL
NOD TO HIS FATHER'RLFLUENCE.
>> IN THE STATE HERE WAS AT
THE TI TT A LOT OF
ATTENTION.
THERE WAS A CROWD THATO
STAY OUT LATE AND, YOU KNOW,
HA. AL
SAY IT WUSE
>> HE T ONLOOR OF
THE STATHOUSPEHIS ELLBINDING MO.
>> Rte GAETZHED ON TO A TOOL TH
HELPFY VOICE.
>> HIS APPROAC TWITTER
DEFITE ANTICIPATED THE TRUMP
ERA.
>> Reporter: IN 2016, GAETZ RAN
AGAIN.
THIS TIME FOR A FLOR
CONGRESSIONAL SEATD N.
>> HEY, W ARE YOU DOING?
>> THIS Y MOTHER.
>> HEY,
NICE TO SEYOU.
YEAR. INGTON
COME ON UP, MATT.TT GAETZ.
I JUST WATCHEDAST NIGH
ONEVISION. WAS FANTASTIC>> Repte
UP TO NEWLY D PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>>, ESIDENT, IT'S MATT
GAETZ.
ANYTHING, SIR.
JUST CALLINGO  YOU, U D A GREAT.
DON'T LET THESE PEOP
DOWN. FOR
YOU WITH ALL WE'VE GOT.
BECOMIN
>> Reporter: AIE CONGRESS.CU RA
>> WHAT WE SEE IN THIS
KANGAO COURT
CHAIRMANF IS ACTING
ALAROO.
>> Reporter: A BRAZE
OVN
RM ISLIN 2019, LEADING A GROUP
CLOOR DEPOSITIONHAHAPPENING DURA
PROCEEDINGS.
>> WE'RE GOINGO I INSIDE.
WITH THIS TWABCHAEL LY THREATEN
DAMAGING PERSONAL INFORMATION
AHEAD OFOHEN
TESTIMONY.
AFTER ANR THATE COULD
NESS  GAETZ ISSUED A
OLIN MEAR, HE WORE AMASK WG ON
FLOOR OF T UOCKING
CONCERN THAT WAS RISING OVER THE
SPREAD OF CO.ANTH DAYS LATER,
HAO SELFR
COMING INTO CONTACT WITH SOMEONE
WHO D TESTED PE FOTHE
RU DEFEAT LIAINNY TH
UPION.
LEAD A RALLY AGAINST HER  ICH F
PRP.
>> I'VE BEEN HERE FOR ABOUT AN
HOUR AND I IHE PCE LOT BETTER TN
YOURIDIVE
LIZ CHENEY.
>> Reporter: THE CONGRESSMANR T
HAS A 19OLD SON, A CUB
IMMIGRANT HE SAYS HE'SN
PARENTING FOR A NUMBER OS DAD.
>>E RAISED HIM FOR THE LAST X A
ENGAGE TAFTER PROPOSING TO HIS
26-YEAR-OLD GIRLFRIE
AS HE IS FIG
POLITICA AMID ALL THESALGAW WIL
HUGE MOMENT